let's make it a little trickier let's um
let's do a couple of different fractures
together rather than a full bar model
and the fraction okay this time we're
going to go one quarter I think about
what would it mean if we say multiply
that by two fits okay now this is very
similar to what we just did right in
fact the numbers I've deliberately
chosen quite someone what's the
difference well let's do this canceling
thing let's try this out okay what's in
common what can you see that's in common
yeah so for just like in our previous
example so if I cancel this what should
I divide it by 2 which leaves me with my
I'm just like before okay it's all this
I'll be left with two okay are there any
other things that I can cancel no there
aren't are there I mean that one not two
not five they don't really go to mix
together they have no common factors
okay so you can see how fractions is
built on what we remember from whole
numbers so what's left behind after I've
canceled everything well I've got one
and one over here and then I've got two
and five threes this is a half of a
fifth a half of a fifth draw that
okay if i divide this up into fifths
roughly ok and now I take one of these
fits what of them and I just want half
like this
okay you see I've got a half of a fifth
now right well how much is the green
area how many of those how many of these
green things can I fit in the whole
video shop I can fit 10 of them right so
that green thing is a 10 you want to see
me when I'm angry now therefore you can
see where is this 10 card from clearly
it comes from the two and five right 1 x
1 numerators multiply to give you 12 x 5
denominators multiply they give you 10
here yeah okay so what have I done it's
a little bit like what we did with
equivalent fractions so if I gave me
something like this oh that's not
calibrated order three sixths 36 we get
cancelling in this situation don't we we
understand cancelling here because it's
all on the same fraction Oh pic pic now
okay fine nachos gonna be real honest no
threat I'll keep I keep I'll keep red as
kids so I see there's a common factor
here right three I can / sorry that's a
1/3 and divide the bottom by 3 as well
it's that ok now it just so happens that
over in this case right the numbers
which have common factors the two and
the four this separate it out they're
not on the same fraction okay what if I
flip them together they will be on the
same fraction okay if you like without
cancelling
that's right i can write this as one
times two numerators on four times five
now they are the same fraction you can
cancel it just like you would have with
a regular fractured that okay good
question